che bello fare un blog con un po di
qualità video che in genere la qualità
video dei miei blog fa sempre vomitare
gli sgombri morti.la tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fra
vj ed oggi siamo in un nuovo logo un po
pieno di cagate perché durante la
settimana sono successe diverse cose
partiamo con il titolo di questo video
che devo far fare degli scherzi a questa
persona devo fare degli scherzi a questa
lui devo fame è proprio devo farlo
quando sono venuti a casa mia hai
ragazzi quindi lui e suo fratello gli ho
fatto credere di aver invocato il
demonio con la tavola uil di notte li
mettevo gli effetti sonori horror questa
non volevo neanche detto periodi notte
che a chi dorme qui a casa mia metto
l'audio horror perché ho le casse
bluetooth e sono proprio una persona
simpatica tutti vogliono essere miei
amici hanno logato tutti e due con i
loro profili facebook
instagram sui miei computer e quindi io
nel corso del tempo gli ho cambiato
tutte le descrizioni gli ho messo dei
posti facendo loro credere che gli
avessero creato il profilo in realtà ero
io il sun ragazzi in pochissimo tempo
devastato la vita di quest'uomo è come
se non bastasse qualche giorno fa è
venuto a trovarmi di nuovo arco è venuta
a milano perché aveva un evento e mi ha
chiesto se poteva passare la notte da me
[Musica]
siccome io sono super ospitare gli ho
detto certo voglia che poi passarono per
me stai quanto vuoi solo che l'evento
era il pomeriggio lui sarebbe arrivato a
casa mia rialzo ora di cena verso ora di
cena marco mi manda un messaggio con su
scritto guarda lorenzo faccio un po
tardi e non riesco ad arrivare per ora
di cena arriva un pochettino dopo mentre
mi arriva questo messaggio io ero in
chiamata con il fratello di marco caso è
stato assurdo
ho detto al fratello di marco che
marchio sarebbe arrivato un po più tardi
e il fratello mi ha detto facciamogli
uno scherzo fargliela pesare come se te
la fossi presa tantissimo visto che lui
è una persona sensibile abbiamo fatto
questo scherzo telefonico a marco nel
mentre che io ero in chiamata con suo
fratello vi lascia lo scherzo
diciamo io ciccio saluto ciao ragazzi e
ciccio che il fratello di marco vi mando
un locale dove li dico sì però marco
descrivendo dove lo faccio mi faccio
prendere male dice cosa che avrei potuto
mangiare adesso chi venderlo che si fa
un terriccio
io sono prontissimo tolgo le cuffie
perché se tu ridi vien da ridere
intonato il coro le cuffie però se ci si
sente quindi ok
eccomi marco no scusami se ti mando
questo vocale adesso voglio solo dire
che allora di base cioè non sono mai
lasciato un po così perché comunque
quando quando non lo so un amico viene a
casa di qualcuno cioè non è che gli che
lo lascia la serata da solo
cioè io adesso sono le sabato sera è
quasi ora di ce ne sono da solo con uno
stronzo no cioè non è che voglio fare
veramente lo stronzo però e per dirti
cioè se cose non si fa non voglio dire
un minimo di vita atto anche perché
comunque io ci tenevo se mio amico
quindi vieni a casa mia però non mi
lasciare così voglio dire tu vieni a
dormire bovino a dormire casa tipo di a
casa mia è sempre aperta prova cioè non
trattarmi come un pezzo di merda tutto
qua niente ciao
no ragazzi veramente io mamma mia
l'applauso aspetta che voglio vedere la
risposta il nuovo volto di secondo dimmi
tutto o mini scusa insomma mi aspettavo
per l 8 a 0
no ma tranquilli non ti preoccupare io è
una roba
cioè mi sono sentito un po dimenticato
da dio però senti potevi dirmelo prima
storari c'è cazzo non puoi adesso no ma
voglio dice potevi dirmelo prima nel
senso magari mangia tranquillo ci hai
capito
qui quindi la specie di capitano in atti
quindi che facciamo facciamo che con gli
anni ma ti sto prendendo per il culo che
abbiamo organizzato io e ciccio zio che
tu sei sempre brancato a casa mia ti
prendiamo sempre per il tour ma io sono
sensibile ci vediamo dopo ti mando un
bacio è la lingua è finita per noi ciao
vinny marchio sono solo quattro prank
per adesso ci siamo visti solo due volte
quindi preparati che non abbiamo finito
passando ad altro ragazzi durante la
settimana è uscito il video con cui ho
fatto a botte con mio papà con le spade
grosse abbiamo registrato questa roba in
un disney store o anche delle clip del
disney store che sono dei backstage che
dovete assolutamente guardare perché
sono etici la magia
e allora capisco una perché questo
specchio mi sta dando del cavallo mentre
mata mia casa dei sogni possono davvero
diventare visto papa ha detto che il mio
sogno diventare una realtà guarda c'è un
cavallo papa specchio che funziona
perché non provo anche io di remo
insieme sì sì sì sì
harry potter ma no non era quella per
che ride papa
stanno uscendo un sacco di video della
madonna e tutti quanti mi state facendo
i complimenti io vi ringrazio
non abbiamo ancora finito perché questa
settimana ovvero martedì uscirà al video
sia sul mio canale sia sul canale
dimette mise dove abbiamo fatto una cosa
schifosa non visse poi ora nulla però
guarda te sta roba
tanto più schifo no no no no ma il calo
è come se fosse un piatto grande nave il
pranzo dei qua c'è dentro il caso ve lo
stesse chiedendo ma forse l'avrete già
capito quella roba lì che abbiamo
mangiato era era cibo per cani hanno
fatto un pre c'è non è un prank ma quasi
perché non me l'aveva detto e abbiamo
fatto una mail in dove abbiamo mangiato
del cibo per cani
io ho mangiato del cibo per cani
commette bizet
d'accordo ragazzi queste voi siete più
vero aggiornati su tutte le cose che
sono successe che succederanno un'ultima
cosa che prima di con cui questa volta
di quanto è bello abbiamo una nuova
animazione a fine video ragazzi credo lo
sappiate tutti perché ieri ho postato su
twitter su facebook su instagram da mio
padre da mia nonna e su youtube
il fatto che alla fine dei video non ci
sarà più quel televisore merdoso di
prima ma ci sarà l'animazione che state
per vedere visto che adesso si conclude
il video la metto la canzone di
sottofondo l'ha fatta o meglio la sta
facendo gabry ponte secondo me è una
bomba ragazzi o con quello che il video
perché voglio vederla quindi guardate la
figaggine sigla
[Musica]